a little bit about me first I've been an
AR user for around six years I first
learned at Rice University where I went
for undergraduate I'm currently a data
scientist at data camp I started just
two weeks ago for those of you who
aren't familiar with them they're a data
science online education company and
they're sponsoring this conference you
can go learn more about them at the
booth and a couple things I enjoy
talking about if you find me at lunch or
in the coffee breaks a be testing the
talk I gave at Jared's Meetup was all
about online experimentation I did a lot
of it at Etsy where I was before and
currently helping data camp build out
their platform building and finding data
science community this is really why I
enjoy being at conferences like this
because all the talks are recorded which
is great for those who can't make it so
you could see these talks but really
it's the energy in the room it's the
connections that you make when you see
people and the coffee and the lunch that
makes it so much fun to be here and
finally of course are alright I have
three goals for my talk today the first
is to keep you hip to the lingo so I'm
talking about the tidy verse but but
what is this tidy verse you know what
how did it come about and who are the
people behind it and the second is to
stop you from doing this we've all had
those moments where we know exactly what
we want our data set to look like how we
want to reshape it or the model and it
just won't work hoping to help solve
that by teaching you some useful
functions you can start doing right away
in your workflow and finally point you
to some resources I'm hoping at the end
of this talk you'll be excited to learn
even more about the tidy verse after
understanding better its its breadth and
how the functions can work with your
data analysis process and I want to help
you start that journey so that will be
the closing part of this talk all right
the tidy verse tidy verse is a set of
our packages that are designed to work
really well together and to bring you
through the data analysis process this
is what the tidy verse universe looks
like most of us are probably familiar
with these steps first you have to even
get your data into R then you work on
changing it maybe you have to munch some
dates probably you'll try it out
visualizations plotting your data
hopeless ggplot2 and then the final step
is usually to communicate it to other
people you might do that through a shiny
interactive dashboard or an arm markdown
document that you make to a Google Doc
that you share with stakeholders and
what we see throughout this process is
written below the big steps import
transform are just some of the tidy
verse packages that can help you through
this now most of you here are probably
familiar with this man he is gonna be
speaking had Lee Wickham for those of
you don't know who's the author behind
such packages as deep liar and ggplot2
and if you've been around in our for a
few years you might have heard the term
the Hadley verse talking about these
packages so a question could be is a
tidy verse just to have the verse it
just had Lee Wickham the answer is
absolutely not yeah this is the first
time I think I've had having in the
audience for this but what I wanted to
show with this is that Holly's done a
great job starting this but here are
some of the packages in the tidy verse
and these are the people behind them in
some cases they're the creators of the
package in other cases they're the
current maintainer or active developers
without whom the package wouldn't look
like how it is today and that's what I
really wanted to emphasize is it's grown
you know much beyond one person and
really now there are lots of
contributors lots of packages in the
tidy verse and it makes it a really
exciting place to be the main part of my
talk is going to be this demonstration
I'm gonna walk through and explore to
our data analysis of cattles data
science and machine learning survey this
was something they did in 2017 they
surveyed about 16,000 people ranging
from those just starting in data science
to people already in the field asking
questions on their demographic
information what are their favorite
learning platforms or what machine
learning methods are they excited about
next year and some steps of a data
analysis work fall walkthrough going
from everything to viewing our data set
initially inspecting some different
columns making plots and maybe
everyone's favorite steps doing
something really cool and new alright so
first up you just type the name of your
data set after you've imported it into
your console and who's ever had this
happen
where it just takes over the whole thing
and you're like oh no what what have I
done what mistakes have I made and
what's happened is you have so many
columns and it's printing all of them
out and this is really not a useful way
to view your data set because it's just
completely taken over in the solution to
this is to use the function as table
from the table package
Tibbals our modern data frames and
they've changed a few behaviors about
data frames but one of the great ones is
that they will only print the first ten
rows and the columns that fit on the
screen so we can see here is those rest
of those columns that were the rows of
those were all printing out now we just
see the column name along with its type
so this is you never have to worry about
that never-ending console screen again I
guess unless you have maybe 10,000
columns don't do that next up
examine your n A's as we heard an
earlier talk missing values can be
really important so how do you take a
look and see what those missing values
might be one way you can do it is first
you do its combination of sum and is dot
n a is Don n a will change the variable
country to true or false depending on
whether it's missing then we sum it and
because true evaluates to 1 and false to
0 that gets us the number of Na s and
using D priors summarize we can get this
so that now we have you know just a one
row data set that's the number of n A's
and it's 0 but how can we do this for
every column I don't want to be running
through each column name doing this
here's where per can come in so per to
me initially was a very intimidating
package it's all about functional
programming it has a lot of stuff but I
just want to share it with those who
aren't familiar how how you can start
using it and what here I'm going to do
is map this function sum is na over
every column the map underscore DF says
I want to dataframe back so you have map
underscore CHR I want to character back
and that's how you tell that's and we
can see I do get indeed back a data
frame of one row and 228 columns and
what's in the row here is a number of n
A's in that column and the way I've said
this is the dot that's in here says this
is where the column should go this is
what I want where I want you to the
function and that little tilde just
stands for an anonymous fun
and this is a really nice way to do
something over every column what's a
problem here let's take a look at gender
select it's said that there were zero
anaise well what do we see here as
humans there are 95 people where it's an
empty string and we recognize that as an
A but R doesn't and are missing so our
missing values aren't actually an A to
solve this we can use D pliers and a F
and this says if it's argument is what
we want to change to n/a in this case we
want to change an empty string to an A
and now if we once again look at our
gender select variable we see just as we
would hope the 95 entries RNA next step
let's examine some of our numeric
columns but how can we do this quickly
we're gonna use a combination of deep
higher selective and skim our skin
select if if you're probably you might
be familiar with deep layers select
select if says I only want to select the
columns if a condition is met in this
case that the numeric and then skimmer
skim gives us a really quick overview
this is all this a lot of the summary
information you'd probably want starting
with how many are the missing what's the
mean standard deviation what are the
percentiles and finally probably my
favorite feature the histogram where we
can and we can immediately start seeing
some things like oh we might have a data
quality issue because age the minimum
age is zero and the maximum is 100
probably we didn't have zero olds taking
our survey next let's go back and
examine a single column this is the
column work method select and I'm just
doing a count and I'm seeing okay which
you know let's summarize the data a bit
and see what are the more popular work
method select what's an issue we have
here we can see that this must have been
a multiple selection question so each
row is you know represents like a person
to answer and the problem we have here
is some of the answers have to work
method selected like we see the third
wrote data visualization common logistic
regression so if we want to understand
what's the most popular work method this
is not a really good format for our data
to be in and to the helpless we're gonna
use the stringer function string
underscore split stringer is all about
working with strings
in this case we'll say take that work
method select column split it based on
the comma with that make a new column
work underscore method and let's take a
look at that and now what we have is a
column of lists so that first row is a
list is a character list of five entries
and that used to be five things split by
four commas but now we've got a list but
that's not the format we wanted it to be
in so how can we spread it out so now
once again each row will only have a
single entry and with that we do tidy
our son nests so we take this data set
which has a list in each row and we
spread it out and we end up with over
68,000 rows because now it's much longer
and with that we can start trying to
visualize so let's make a plot let's do
a plot of you know as we wanted to ask
what are the most common work methods
and we have a critical issue with this
plot which is it's a mess this is not
helpful right what what what the heck
are these XS what are the labels so
we're gonna do two things to solve this
the first is a cord flip and this is
really nice you the other option would
be you can make your x axis labels
vertical instead of horizontal but I
personally like the cord flip a lot and
now we can read it and and that's okay
that's more helpful but we still have a
problem they're not ordered so let's
let's order them and with that we can
use for cats was one of my favorite
packages it's around working with
factors and here we're saying okay let's
reorder the work method column by n by
the number of people and now we can see
that oh great this is much easier to
read we see we start data visualization
logistic regression are the most popular
verses like GM's are all the way at the
bottom not very popular our final step
in a date analysis process right as we
heard is it's maybe just a 5 or 10% a
time but it's doing something cool and
new what's the issue we have here we
have no idea what we're doing so who's
running together you're so excited about
a new method and you're like I don't
even know where to start or I just ran
into a bug and why isn't my code working
there's a lot of options you have here
such as reading the manual but another
option is that you can
ask a question see and you if you want
to make ask a good question like say on
sec overflow our studio community or
twitter a good way to do is to make a
minimal reproducible example which is
all about helping others help you and
we're gonna do this with two packages
Tibble and rep ryx and first just to
clarify a minimal we producible example
is let's say you asked a question it
says why is in fact to reorder working
would be very difficult for anyone to
answer that for you so they wouldn't see
your code they wouldn't know what
dataset you're working at but what if
your code is a thousand lines and your
data set is proprietary well you can't
really share that either so a minimal
reproducible example is about reducing
your code to where it's to the shortest
possible amount of code and data that
still illustrates the problem you're
having and this is an optional part but
one way if you need to make a kind of
fake data set to do this you can use
Tribble to make a toy data set and
Tribble is how I always dreamed of
making data sets in art which is just on
the first row you list your column names
a little tilde before it and the next
row is just all the entries and here I'm
just saving that as an original data
frame next up we can use the package
reference from Jenny Brian to find any
problems what do I mean by that let's
say we have our code so on the left here
we've said okay this is the code that's
having a problem let me try rhetorics
i copy it and run ref rex but oh no i'm
having errors so if someone was running
this in a clean our session they would
have errors and not the errors i want
them to have but but the errors because
I haven't loaded the packages so in this
case if we look at what errors are gonna
come out it's oh I don't I can't find
the function business I can't find the
function ggplot we go back to our code
and realize we haven't done the library
calls so rep Rex will help you find
those issues before you post and someone
goes back and says hey I can't run your
code then we can use refworks to post
your question or issue and that's really
nice say in this case we're seeing an
example where you posted it on on github
like maybe you want to file a bug report
with a package and the nice thing is if
formats your code and includes any plots
and makes it really easy just to go and
submit your issue just by copying it
all right so this is just an overview of
what we went through today about 11
functions like I said there are so many
more not just packages but functions
within the packages and that's why I
wanted to go over for example deep wire
which is a very popular package but many
people don't realize the depth of the
functions that it has and at the
resource at the end I'm going to point
you to some places where you can find
out things like that first Resource is
Hadley wickham's and Garrett Crowell
Aman's are for data science book which
will probably be given away at this
conference it's available for free
online and it's a really good resource
it's appropriate for both beginners so
if you're just starting out in our but
also even for more advanced our users
who are looking either - maybe wholesale
switch into the tidy verse or I've been
using the tidy verse but aren't familiar
with certain parts such as may be
working with dates and then they can go
to this book and just jump to the
chapter or section on that next step is
the our stats Twitter hashtag so I'm a
big Twitter user and one of the reason I
like it is it's a very friendly
community in this case I was saying I
have a what happened was I had a report
that I was writing at Etsy and I had
about 12 plots in it but I was going to
share this with a lot of people so I
wanted to make those plots use the etsy
color scheme and I knew about theme
underscore set which is a way at the top
of your your script you can set the
background for your plot and that will
change all the plots later but that
didn't work for colors and I wanted to
know how can I change globally change
the colors on my plot without having to
go and every single plot add the color
scale that I wanted and our sets Twitter
came to the rescue so LD Sessler here
said did you know about this package GG
theme our here's the functions in it and
here's a blog post I wrote about it and
this was a really nice way to get it get
an answer to my question that the
googling hadn't hadn't done for me next
up our studio has lots of cheat sheets
you can find them at their table in the
back this is per I like it again as both
a reference but per is often thought of
mainly for its map function but this is
a two-sided cheat sheet and there's so
many more functions that you have here
so whether it's you want to dive into a
package or you want a one
stop shop for working with strings you
can go to our studio cheat sheets and
find those now of course I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention my company data camp
I actually had this in my presentation
even before I worked with them and
that's part of why I was so excited to
join as I mentioned it's a data science
online education company and it's a
little bit different we have a couple of
things we have projects and problem sets
but one of our main things is courses
and these courses are for hours so
they're a lot shorter than say a
Coursera course which might run over a
few months we have people like you know
Charlotte Wickham Hadley has a course
I'm working on a course right now in
categorical variables and the way these
courses work as you watch videos and
then you do these interactive exercises
right in your browser so it's a nice way
if you're just starting to learn like
our Python or sequel to not have to
download anything and to get immediate
feedback
all right in conclusion I wanted to say
again that you know our has we're great
we have as Kristine Zhang here is
sharing we have all these awesome
stickers again you can find some of them
in the back cool package names but so
maybe maybe that's how we can help
attract people initially but really
staying for the friendly community and
happy workflow and that's part of why I
love so much being part of the art
community I work with our ladies global
organization advancing gender equality
in the art community and we've had such
an outpouring of support from a lot of
other people in terms of sponsorships
and I really think that just shows that
ours is really the people helping lead
our do not want to be elitist they don't
want to exclude others are is meant for
people who in some cases are never going
to be professional developers but and
that's kind of what the tidy verse is
about is even even if you don't want to
go deep into I'd say like advanced
programming which you definitely can and
are the tardy versus get you doing
powerful things very quickly with that I
want to say you can find my slides very
soon on this Lake tiny dot CC New York
our talk I blog about some of these
topics like finding data science
community making our faster on my blog
hooked on data can find me on Twitter
Robinson
underscore yes and with that thank you
all so much
[Applause]
you